why not okay my opponent said the stream
is muted and the engine is off I hope so
man no engines all right I like this I'm
gonna go with it the Trump of ski who
knows about the Trump hop scheme huh
still a lot more to learn on this for
sure now naive for things he get really
crazy followed up with c5 especially if
nightly for Bishop h4 there's like a g4
and then in between move f3 and crazy
town so now what what is the scoop okay
well I might want to just go right in
for it and say deal with this compromise
pawn structure and I'm gonna have to be
very cautious about what what must I be
cautious about what color squares pop
quiz very quick question in the twitch
chat answer it who's getting it if there
are squares I need to take care of what
color ones are they going to be the
important ones to watch out for yes
catching it out of the corner of my eye
blitz king dub mont bill several why
dark because i don't have a dark square
Bishop that's the main reason so if i'm
going to not have my darks for Bishop
these guys right here they home sudden
have a job
Bishop said alright guys i'm going to
shatter the structure a bit compromised
it and you will now have two out save
the day you'll have to take care of the
duty i once had so Bishop d3 why not
it's a good question and I don't have a
good reason not to there's no bishop pin
I don't know about the bishop move here
I think going to d6 is good for a couple
of reasons one its more aggressively
placed at staring at one of my pawns at
least into taking into account what
files are open door half opened what do
we have here with regard to the e-file
the e-file is half opened in a rook
eventually would like to be placed here
most likely it's a pretty logical move
but if it's played there the bishop is
just acting as a blindfold to a rook
eventually coming to this half open file
so I'm not sure what this is doing I
guess preparing a one idea i'm seeing
for black is to play f5 and then this
night will go out take a little hike d 7
f-6 efore that'd be nice square I think
I should do this 92 and i'll be looking
into maybe a c4 I want to challenge this
pond ok now this night is what is he
getting ready to do play here I was just
going to place III but you know what I
think just watching over be4 with the a
pond and then still allow for this c4
advance if I play to c3 well I can't be
doing two things my sepan can't watch
out for both these squares kim can they
can't go to c4 and still be watching v 4
so the a pond has this role in other
words this guy may be c4 at some point i
might want to get some more pieces
involved I'm hesitant to play I was
hesitant to be playing my knight to e 2
because I didn't want maybe the bishop
coming out here I don't know how
annoying of a pin that would be but
anyhow I was thinking about just not
going there right away and instead
that's why i did go with the Queen night
and this is a typical square but i think
the e 2 squared turns out to be better
one reason for this is because i'm
seeing possibilities of attacking this
light square Bishop and this pond I've
also seen you know what maybe I should
take some things back because this
earlier idea of Bishop d3 I think
there's another placement for it and it
comes by way of playing g3 and Bishop g2
really focusing on this pond and maybe
even the Queen side light squares so
often maybe touch on that for a second
or two after the game but anyhow about
c4 right now I think that's looking
pretty good so let's do it why not
trying to get rid of blacks only center
pond and then there will be a 220
majority in fact black is allowing for
white to obtain a 2 vs 0 majority in the
center
as soon as they play to that c 6 square
all right the sepan cannot contribute
with the defense with the support of the
d5 square the d5 pump so no one what's
the plan what our blacks candidate moon
was ok and now offer light square Bishop
exchange or play here and hit this
Bishop if your opponent has the dark or
the bishop pair having one pair of
bishops come off the board is usually a
very good thing could do this and I am
welcoming that sort of exchange if I do
this I'm ready to grab that guy I'm not
so sure I'm worried of the dark squared
bishop or am I night here bishop will go
back yeah actually I like the night move
it's that dark squared bishop and well
you know come to think of it this a pond
is not only stopped in the night move
but the bishop move as well Bishop check
I don't know how knowing that would have
been if it did play there i have Knight
c3 available but anyhow serving a useful
role I don't have anything else other
than to recapture and I think I just do
what next what's the plan rook here can
excite castle the Queen could be playing
here hitting this pond a second time
maybe my night wants to do something
else yeah let's get my night working i
don't i don't want to Castle just yet
i'm looking to get this bish up with
either night be five or four next I like
that my bishop is opposite this king I'm
seeing that if the position becomes a
bit more simplified an endgame I'm
seeing still the possibility for me to
target f7 with a rook maybe getting to
the seventh rank and I think well this
Bishop is going to be dead now so i
could play here or here i'm going to go
here just instinctually
because I know it's a safe square it's
it's a more I guess harmonious it's
protected efore is going to be quite
alright as well I'm sure but just play I
guess extra cautious to avoid any
nonsense to avoid any silly little
tactics that black might have I could
have also considered be four instead of
castle but I think a five would come be
for his intention would be to stop this
c5 advance I think an idea would be to
clamp down on this is C 5 square and I
think that's a very purposeful move
getting it off of this diagonal because
maybe there are ideas of me taking and
then taking here with check and being on
the Queen 30 seconds left for black and
I don't know that that could be I don't
know that that's a good idea my last
decision I think this is my last main
decision and it involves my bishop my
rooks definitely know where they want to
go get on this diagonal pivot about on
c5 which is the square that has been
weakened because of that a b5 move and I
could play here but the Queen takes my
idea here is just going to be to pile up
in that pond and it was not taken into
account their time pressure for both of
us with only one open file you don't
want to maintain control over i'll look
into h3 and g4 or even King f 1 e 2 D 3
let's do this there is this fork I'm not
so afraid of that just work on my king
position take with my pond I like my
king position although this is maybe an
idea okay let's stop it all together
that King is getting pretty excited
there what is he doing the king right
here would have been pretty interesting
let's get out of there I'm just focusing
on my king position right there towards
the end all right good game good game
let me uh let me back up my opponent was
saying that they weren't too familiar
with the Trump offski well I'm not I'm
not too familiar with it
I'm still having to learn quite a bit
about it but let's have a look a closer
look at this structure that could
definitely come about from this Trump
offski so after this exchange now this
is one that I'm not to I don't know if
you should be going with that I think
both both could be played yeah I'm
pretty sure both could definitely be
played but I'm more familiar with this
type of structure and it's one that I
get into quite a bit out of the
caro-kann after there's that mainline
continuation and knight on e4 and I just
bring the night out right away instead
of the main line Bishop to f5 going
Knight f6 quite a bit and we have a
similar structure with this double def
palm are the double def ponds yeah so I
think considered going like this and
then getting your bishop out to this f 5
squares one way to go about things and
also you I think really considering
bishop d6 again it's more active and
once your castled and you play your rook
to e8 you know your Bishop will be out
of the way of your rook once a place to
the half open file so that's another way
to look at you know if you're wondering
well is there really a difference
between the two well now you could at
least be assigning differences between
these two points I think it's a you know
when you're when you're in term if
you're playing chess pretty seriously
and especially when it comes to
tournament play I think it's it's a good
feeling to be able to have a good reason
behind why maybe d6 is going to be
better than e7 I think that I'll start
to build your own confidence in your own
game so hopefully these reasons are
helpful they may seem quite simple but
um you know anyhow it's I think a really
act as a good confidence booster in your
own game that's so sure about the pawn
push if you really want to you could
just play here if your intention is to
shut down the bishop
from having pressure on that diagonal
bata what's the fact what's the plan
here I don't know about the night move I
was starting to feel very comfortable as
soon as your night played here I think
an idea to run with and it was something
i was saying during the game is f5 and
then transfer your queen night so that
it starts to look like a king night in
other words get it to f6f 597 to f 64
look into that idea that maneuver might
be quite good I think there's there's
not much else for you here because I'm
taking out a strong piece eventually
there's no way to stop my night from
attacking this Bishop there's two
squares available you can't guard both
b5 and e4 in this case and I don't have
any structural damage i just have the
bishop pair so things are looking good
for black here and this is something
that turns out to just hurt i know
there's time issues at this point but
I'm after b5 it's just hurting your
position it's allowing for me to pivot
on c5 function laterally and basically
just stay there cannot be dislodged so
don't don't do that b5 move you're just
compromising your position but out the
earlier points the bishop the Darkstar
bishops deployment and the the idea of
bringing the Queen night over to this FF
6 square and then maybe later efore I
think is something to be looking into
and also just working with a different
structure all together this right here
instead of capturing with the epon you
can be looking into capturing with this
pump okay